[MUSIC PLAYING]
WESTON HUTCHINS: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to the
longest session title
that you'll probably see
it at Google Cloud Next.
We tried to see how far
we could wrap arounds.
But really, this is
a much shorter title.
Multi-Cluster Management
of the GKE On-Prem.
We had to keep it a little
bit hidden until the day
one announcements.
But now that we've
talked about GKE On-Prem,
we're going to do a little
deep dive today, show you
guys what we have, and give
you more information on what
we've built out.
So quick intros.
My name is Weston
Hutchins, Product Manager
on the GKE team.
MATT DE LEO: I'm Matt De Leo.
I'm Product Manager
on the team, as well.
NAKHEEL: And I'm Nakheel,
Software Engineer on GKE team.
WESTON HUTCHINS: OK.
So I've got a little
story to tell.
I'm going to sit down.
We started this demo by
wheeling our entire rack
from backstage out here.
And we're debugging some issues.
We ran into a little
SNAFU where we couldn't
get an IP address for the rack.
So we're going to
wait on the demo.
We moved it all the
way backstage again.
And Nakheel is
actively debugging.
I hope to be able to
show a demo for this.
We'll try to come
back to it later.
But right now, we're just
going to jump into slides.
Nobody said On-Prem was easy.
Clearly we're learning
that up on stage here.
So I'm going to start by
giving a little background
on our journey to Cloud
Services Platform.
A little history
lesson here is about we
started with mainframes.
We started with big boxes.
And every evolution
since then has
been trying to move further
and further up the stack.
So along came virtual machines
which [INAUDIBLE] the hardware
and allowed you to spin
up multiple machines
on the same host.
And then containers
came into popularity.
Now containers have
actually been around
for quite some time.
Google has been working with
containers for over 15 years.
But we didn't really start
to see widespread adoption
until Docker.
Around 2013, when Docker
unveiled their stack
for a lightweight container
runtime with great packaging
portability and
deployment semantics
around these environments
where you could really
package up your application
interdependencies
and move it from
host to host, that's
where we started to see
containers actually becoming
a reality.
But of course, Docker
solved the problem
of taking an app
and its dependencies
and deploying it
onto a single host.
That was never going
to be the end journey.
We always needed something
a little bit more.
And this was around the
time that the team started
to think about Kubernetes.
So how do you take not
just a single container
on a single host--
how do you take
multiple containers
across multiple
hosts and orchestrate
that over a fleet
of virtual machines?
So Google started to take
all of the lessons we've
learned from our internal
container management system,
Borg, externalize
those with Kubernetes.
But as [INAUDIBLE] said
in the day one keynote,
Kubernetes was also
never the end state.
It really is that consistency
layer between infrastructure
and then higher level services.
It allows the operators
to think about what's
provisioned underneath
and allows the developers
to just worry about
having consistent tooling
between the two.
And a lot of the announcements
that you guys have
seen at GCP Cloud Next have been
focused on these higher level
services.
So we talked about
Knative in the keynote
this morning, which offers
serverless and some paths level
functionality that can
run on top of Kubernetes.
We announced Istio
1.0 GA, which is
the service mesh capabilities
to actually think
not just about
Kubernetes deployments,
but how services connect
and talk to each other
along with how you can control
connections between those
with security and
everything else.
And then there's not tools
that just Google has,
but the community has built
in the open source, as well.
So we have CIDC tools.
We have monitoring and logging
agents like Prometheus.
We have things like
the Open Service Broker
where we actually can
connect to services running
in Cloud using an open API.
And our customers came to
us and they said, well,
we love these open
source [INAUDIBLE],,
but we want you guys
to manage it for us.
And this is where we started
offering hosted versions
of all of these solutions.
So Kubernetes became
Google Kubernetes Engine,
our hosted managed offering.
We run that on top of
our infrastructure stack.
And a lot of the
announcements today
came out for serverless
for GKE and Istio for GKE.
These are managed
offerings that we
want to install inside
your Kubernetes cluster
so that you can think about
the important thing, which
is application
development, and not
having to manage infrastructure.
But of course, just like
one host on a container
wasn't enough and we
needed Kubernetes,
we're now entering the realm
of Multi-Cluster Management
management.
So one cluster is not enough.
We have to be able
to spread across
different clusters potentially
in different environments.
And this is where
Matt and team have
been doing a ton
of thinking around
what are the tools
and processes in place
that people can use to
manage multiple clusters?
So single pane of
glass UI, policy
syncing between clusters, CI/CD,
service discovery, and even
some demos that
we're showing off
today of doing multi-cluster
ingress using global load
balancer and federating
out to multiple clusters.
But the big announcement
that we talked
about is really saying, OK,
if we can do this on GKE,
can we do it across
environments?
And this is where the
ideas for GKE On-Prem
started to come into play.
Customers said, we want those
management capabilities of GKE
and all of the service
layers on top of that.
And we want you to run
it in our data center.
And so this is what we've been
working on for quite some time
and trying to really flesh
out the product and the vision
of how we can take
all of the bits
and experience
we've done with GKE
and move that into an
on on-prem experience.
And most of the announcements
on day one and day two
were focused on this
whole family of products
that we've called Cloud
Services Platform that includes
more than just Kubernetes.
It includes all of the tools
that sit on top of Kubernetes,
as well.
And with that, Matt's going
to go into a little bit more
of a deep dive on what it means
to do Multi-Cluster Management.
MATT DE LEO: Thanks, Wes.
Yeah.
So let's take a quick
step back and discuss
what we're seeing as far as why
people need multiple clusters
in the real world.
It is many, many reasons.
So the first one
we see a lot is,
I need to provide
low latency services.
So I've got customers
all over the globe.
And I need to be able to
serve them with low latency
very quickly from wherever the
closest cluster is to them.
You can do this today with the
Google Cloud Load Balancer.
We have a tool that we
build called Kubemci.
And we're working
on some other tools,
as well, to allow
you to do this.
In addition to that, people
often say, you know what?
I really want to have highly
available service running
across regions.
So if I have an outage
in say, US Central,
I want my traffic to failover
to the next closest region.
This is something, again,
that you can leverage
Google's network to do.
And it's something that Kubemci
and multi-cluster ingress,
in general, support.
And in addition, we
often see that customers
have this data locality issue.
So if I've got a customer
that's traveling from--
an end user traveling from one
location to another location--
I need to serve them traffic--
there's traffic to the cluster
that actually has their data.
That's another
important use case.
The other one we see a lot-- and
this is more on the developer
side--
is I need to separate my
teams or maybe my tenants.
Or maybe we want to have
different environments for dev,
staging, and prod.
And when you want to do
that, you necessarily
need multiple clusters.
The other one we
see is if you want
to implement a multi
cloud-- or we'll
get into hybrid in a second--
but a multi cloud strategy.
You also want to use
multiple clusters.
Nobody, as far as I know, really
has a Kubernetes distribution
that can span multiple
providers and still be reliable.
And finally, we often
see that the customers
want to try a new version
of Kubernetes safely.
And they'll try to do it
via Canary in clusters.
And so they'll actually
deploy the same workload
on a new cluster-- a new
version of Kubernetes--
and then they want to
transition the workloads over
from one cluster to another.
So that's why people would
want to use multiple clusters.
But what about hybrid?
So the cloud, we've
determined, must collaborate
with your on-prem And
that's exactly why we're
building GKE On-Prem.
We see a lot where you've
got legacy dependencies
on premises.
You might have an
old database that
really can't move to the cloud.
You might have some
services running
there that really
need to stay on-prem
for a variety of
regulatory reasons.
And those need to stay there.
And you need to be able to
access them from the Cloud.
Another reason is
local execution.
So you might want to
have a cluster running
or your services running in a
warehouse on a factory floor
or in a branch of, say,
a retail operation.
And you might want
to use the CI/CD
to push those things out and
actually control the builds.
The other one we see a lot
is edge computing in IoT.
So this is necessarily
in a situation where you
don't have great connectivity.
And you might have loss of
connectivity to the Cloud,
but you still want to be able to
operate these clusters on-prem.
Another one is
global availability.
Your Cloud provider isn't going
to be exactly in every region
you want to be in, potentially.
And so you can use GKE On-Prem,
or just a hybrid in general,
to provide services
in these locations.
And then, closely tied to
that is the data locality.
So there's a lot of restrictions
on where you can house data.
And you might want to have a
policy that you can enforce.
And you can place it
in a specific location.
And finally, once
you're on-prem,
you can take advantage
of a lot of the things
that your Cloud provider
offers by reaching out
from your on-prem to the Cloud.
And that then
necessarily means you
need to invoke Cloud
services from on-prem.
So as you can see,
it's pretty clear
that you really need to be--
a lot of companies need
to be thinking about being
both on-prem and in the Cloud.
They need to be thinking
about many clusters.
So with that, I'll
say, you know, OK.
Multi-cluster and hybrid
Cloud is a reality.
So what?
It should be easy, right?
It's not.
There's a lot of
challenges with this.
So I have three things
that I'll discuss here.
Workload, services,
and environment.
And the first one
is the workloads.
And there's a lot
of challenges here.
So just deployment and
placement is a big challenge.
You have technical and
business requirements
dictating where you're going
to deploy your services.
And your data
locale requirements
are going to dictate
that, as well.
You probably want to have CI/CD
integration in any solution
you come up with, so
that you have best
practices around deployment.
And then, multi-cluster
introspection is another issue.
How do you ingest all
your logs into one place?
How do you monitor
every service you've
deployed-- every
workload you deployed--
across many environments?
Services, as well, is
another big challenge.
So I discussed this earlier when
I showed the multi-cluster use
cases.
But performance-- low
latency and georedundancy--
that is something
that people often
think about when they're
placing services.
And then this is, again, where
Istio and CSP, in general--
the Cloud Services
Platform-- come in.
We've got identity and security
so you can assign identities
to your workloads.
And you can set up access
controls across environments.
And finally, there's
the environment.
Compute is made a lot
easier with Kubernetes.
It provides them
[INAUDIBLE] layer
above your cloud provider--
above your on-prem environment.
But just having
that isn't enough.
Kubernetes has many
different versions.
If you're trying to
be on the cutting
edge of using the latest and
greatest Kubernetes features,
you might run into challenges
with the API compatibility.
A lot of people run into issues
with OS images and cluster
add-ons.
And so it's not enough just
to say I've got Kubernetes,
and I'm done.
And again, when we think
about identity and security,
there's also user identity and
security and access controls
that come into play here.
How do I audit, say, a
user's access to a cluster?
How do we provide them
the necessary access
to that cluster and
to that namespace
or whatever it happens
to be that they
need to access in there?
And these are all
things that we're
going to be discussing
in the next section,
actually, with GKE On-Prem.
So with that, I'll kick
it back to you, Wes.
WESTON HUTCHINS: I'm going
to check in with Nakheel.
How are we doing?
NAKHEEL: I can register a
cluster, but not [INAUDIBLE]..
I can register a cluster,
but not [INAUDIBLE]..
WESTON HUTCHINS: OK.
We'll check back in
with you in a second.
So let's talk about GKE On-Prem.
I'm going to go to this side
so you guys can see over there.
If you want to get
started with Kubernetes,
one of the biggest
challenges is actually
getting the installation
and configuration correct.
If you go to
Kubernetes.io, it usually
involves wading through over 40
distributions, 60 vendors that
are offering
Kubernetes solutions.
And just choosing the right one
can be a task in and of itself.
Most of the time, people
can get clusters up.
I think the real
challenge that I
hear from a lot of
cluster operators
is how you actually
manage this long term.
This is really where a
lot of the pain lies.
Things like, how do you
encrypt and backup at CD?
How do you do security
patches across your system?
High availability is something
that we've been working on
for a very long time.
It's a very complicated
piece of setup
where you have to
have load balancers
and redundancy
separating [INAUDIBLE]
CD across multiple
failure demands.
And then finally, things like
managing users and policies.
That's also a very
big one when you
start to not just think
about the technical bits
that make up a
cluster, but how you
assign quota and
rate limit those out
across your organization.
Almost every customer that was
using GKE that had some system
on-prem came to us,
and they said, well,
what do you recommend?
And prior to this
week, we said, well,
here's some great options
out there not by Google.
And they said, but what
we really want is GKE,
but we want it on-prem.
We want it in our
own environment.
And so that's when
the team started
going back and
thinking, all right.
Well, maybe we can do this.
Let's start thinking
about what it is.
This is the product
for GKE On-Prem.
Our real goal is to
try and figure out
how we can bring
turnkey, production
grade, easy installation--
the best parts of
the GKE experience--
to your environment.
A lot of the stuff
we've been hearing
is like, if you can just solve
installation and upgrade,
I would be happy.
We want to make sure
that all of these things
are tested and
validated by Google
and that we're constantly
applying security patches.
But we don't want to just
stop at the Kubernetes layer.
A lot of the stuff we're
working on our cloud platform
is expanding the
capabilities of GKE
to offer other higher
level services.
So things like Google Cloud
Build Container Registry,
we have vulnerability
scanning, we
have a number of other features
around, like audit logging.
We want to make these features
that customers can use for GKE
and Google Cloud Platform also
available for our GKE On-Prem
product.
And just as I intro-ed,
Cloud Services Platform
is really sitting on top of this
base layer that is GKE On-Prem.
We want to make sure that
we can offer not just
Kubernetes, but things
like service abstractions,
things like developer tools, and
paths like components that you
can use to give to
your developers.
And that's where Knative, Istio,
and some of the marketplace
solutions come in.
And that alluded to this.
We hear a lot of
people say, well,
the most important thing is
really getting consistent.
It's first off
just the tool stack
that they use to provision
and upgrade Kubernetes.
But it's also ensuring that
you have conformant Kubernetes,
that you have the same add-ons
deployed in every cluster,
you have the same
configuration in every cluster.
People really want
high confidence
that you can take a workload
and make it portable.
And the one real
way to do that is
ensure that your environments
are consistent no matter where
you're deploying.
So for installation
and configuration,
the early focus
for us has really
been getting on a
vSphere environment
for our alpha, which is going
to be available in the fall.
The primitives are really
trying to come up with,
what is that GKE experience
that we can offer?
For the early
versions that we have,
we've been focusing on
an ICLI installation,
supporting things like online
and offline installation,
private container registry
support for people
that are behind firewalls.
And I think one of the most
important pieces of this
is the customers that we've been
talking to want to move fast.
They don't want to have
year-long upgrade cycles.
They see the pace with which we
move with Kubernetes and GKE.
And we want to help them
move at that pace as well.
So moving on the latest
three versions of Kubernetes
and keeping that
rolling window updated
is such a big core component
of what we're trying to offer.
And then we want to take some
of the great features that
we've been working
on for the GKE--
things around high availability
and automatic repair
of your nodes--
to your on-prem environment.
So Nakheel-- I'm going to
check back in on the demo.
How are we doing?
NAKHEEL: I can
register a cluster.
WESTON HUTCHINS:
Should we do that?
NAKHEEL: Yep.
WESTON HUTCHINS: All right.
I'm going to kick it
over to Nakheel, who's
going to show you a quick demo.
NAKHEEL: All right.
So we have GKE On-Prem, which
you can have your own cluster.
But then the next step is,
and really the powerful step
is, when you connect it
to Google Cloud Console.
So here, I'm showing
you a Cloud Console.
And I'm in the clusters view.
And again, before now, you
can list your GKE clusters.
And you see all
the cluster there.
You can go to the workloads
UI and see our workloads
on GKE cluster.
But now what you'll see is we
have this additional register
external cluster.
So what you can do
using this is you
can register your on-prem GKE
cluster with Cloud Console.
So let's try that out.
I'm going to register
external cluster.
It gives me two options.
I can use public
internet connection
to register my cluster.
Or I can use GKE connect.
Let's try GKE connect.
What it's going
to do is it'll ask
me to install a connect
agent into my cluster which
will establish a tunnel from
the cluster to Cloud Console
so that Cloud Console can then
send requests to the cluster.
So let's give my cluster a name.
I wanted to give
it On-prem Cluster.
And now, I download the
manifest which I have
to install into my cluster.
So let's look at what
the manifest looks like.
The manifest has
a service account
that the agent will use.
It has cluster role binding,
and it has a deployment.
This deployment
is the agent that
would run-- that would establish
the tunnel from the cluster
to Cloud Console.
So let's go ahead and apply it.
You can see it created a
service account, cluster role
binding, and a deployment.
And you can see this
is waiting right now.
And hopefully-- fingers
crossed-- if the demo works,
it should show us
a green check mark.
Awesome.
It works.
So now, this shows
that the agent
was able to set up a
connection from the cluster
to Cloud Console.
So let's try the next step.
Now Cloud Console needs
some more information,
which is basically the kube
config information for it
to be able to send Kubernetes
API requests to the cluster.
So let's copy our kube config.
As you can see in this case,
I'm using a Minikube cluster.
It could be a GKE
On-Prem cluster.
It could be a cluster
you brought up yourself.
It could be any Kubernetes
cluster, as long
as it uses the Kubernetes API.
So you go ahead
and authenticate.
And skip authentication for now.
Just let's see
registration works.
Awesome.
Now we see in the same
cluster's list view,
you have your GKE cluster,
which is the East Coast.
And you also have
your on-prem cluster.
If I go to workloads, I
continue to see workloads
from my East Coast cluster.
And ideally, I should see
workloads from this new cluster
that I just registered.
But since I haven't logged
into it, I don't see it.
So let's try to log into it.
I'm sorry I have to
type all of this.
So what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to use the token of
the service account
that I just created
for my agent.
So I can use basic
auth or token.
In this case, I'm
going to use token.
And, voila.
It works.
Now you can see workloads
from your East Coast
cluster and your
on-prem cluster,
all in the workloads view.
If I go back to
my clusters list,
now you can also see total
[INAUDIBLE],, total memory.
Earlier, it was all blank.
Now it can access
all this information.
If I click on my
on-prem cluster,
it shows me even
more information--
this is a [INAUDIBLE]
cluster that's running--
what old storage information
I have, what unloads I have.
In this case, I have just
one cluster, one load, which
is the Minikube API server.
I can go dig deeper.
So this now empowers me to
use all the Cloud Console
functionality that I was able
to use with a GKE server now.
I can now use it with my
any other cluster, as well,
which is great.
WESTON HUTCHINS: Cool.
Thanks, Nakheel.
[APPLAUSE]
We had the demo working
on the rack earlier.
Technical SNAFU.
But, thank you for that.
It shows not just that we
can offer the GKE experience
on the box.
But we can actually take
any Kubernetes cluster
and register with our
Cloud Console now.
So the question I often get
is, like, what does management
mean for GKE On-Prem?
A lot of the stuff
that we want to offer
is a Google managed experience,
both through tooling,
but also through a persistent
connection with our Cloud
Console where we can monitor
and health check and keep things
up to date.
So part of what we're
trying to go out with
is both an option where
Google manages your cluster,
and also, we have partner
supports that can help deploy
these in other environments.
But even outside
of that, we want
to provide extra tooling
above and beyond even what we
have for some of the GKE stuff.
So we want to make sure that we
can get the right metrics out
of the cluster, that we
have automatic repair.
And we even offer some
node management features
such as Node Auto-Upgrades
and Node Repair
that we offer as part of our
GKE on the Cloud experience.
Now logging and monitoring is
a little different in the sense
that we know that
a lot of people
have to have a local logmon
experience for doing debugging.
We don't want to have to egress
everything back to the cloud.
But we do know some people
want the best of both worlds.
So what we're offering
is a pre-built
in cluster dashboard
based off of Prometheus
[INAUDIBLE] CaseStack.
And after you do that, you
can browse everything locally.
You can have the
metrics in your cluster
and do some local debugging.
You can then install
Stackdriver agents
and register with
Google Cloud Console
and have all of these
metrics ingested into GCP.
This is what we demoed
at the keynote on day one
where we were actually showing
metrics coming in and showing
up on top of the service graph.
Now, the real big
power of this is
we want people to use the same
tools to manage both their GKE
clusters in the
cloud and on-prem.
So we want Stackdriver to
be that place where people
go to set alerts and configure
dashboards so that they
can view both clusters
in the same place.
The best part is
that Stackdriver
supports Prometheus as a
data store under the cover.
So there's no extra
instrumentation required.
Identity is an area
where we want--
we're working with
a lot of customers
and trying to figure out how
we can meet their needs on-prem
and also move them to the cloud.
So we know that Active
Directory is going
to be a part of our solution.
We want to integrate natively
with people's local Active
Directory trees.
But for every
feature that you need
to use in Google Cloud Platform,
we need to have a GCP identity.
So we're exploring options,
things like Google Cloud
Directory sync, things
like provisioning
a set of users for use
in our Cloud Console
and all of the GCP services.
We'll have more details about
some of this stuff a little bit
later on.
The other thing that we know
customers are going to want
is the ability to use
their own cert authority
and their own on-prem cluster.
So we're going to
support the ability
to bring your own public
key infrastructure.
Another part of CSP
that we unveiled at Next
is policy management.
So this is a feature that
allows you to create and define
policies using a
declarative configuration,
check those into Git
as a source of truth,
and then federate and sync those
across every cluster that you
have, whether they're running
in the Cloud and on-prem.
So this allows you to
do things like set up
how you want your users to
access all of the clusters
and then manage them
centrally through Google Cloud
Console and the policy
management syncing tools.
There's a bunch
more depth that's
going to be covered
at a session tomorrow
with Ray Colline
and John Murray.
And that-- Thursday at
11:45 in Moscone West
if you want to hear more
about this cool new feature.
And then Nakheel was
saying before, we really
want Cloud Console to be the
place that people come in
and manage all of
their workloads
and manage all of their clusters
from a single pane of glass UI.
GKE On-Prem is special.
This is a Google-managed
Kubernetes offering.
And that's going to
register seamlessly
with Google Cloud Console.
But there will also
have the ability
to take any Kubernetes
cluster, whether they're
running on Minikube locally, or
even in another cloud provider,
and register it with our single
pane of glass solution, which
is what we demoed.
So we're going to skip
that part of it right now.
And Matt is going to tell
you a little bit more
about the GKE connect agents.
MATT DE LEO: Here we go.
All right.
So we quickly showed you a demo
of us connecting from Minikube
back to GCP.
And I want to just do a quick
dive into what we actually did.
So Nakheel mentioned we
installed this connection agent
onto the cluster.
And what this is is
just a deployment
that dials out from
the cluster to Google
and creates a long
live connection.
Once we have that
connection in place,
we have the ability
then to go back
through the connection
the other way
and provide you this single
pane of glass experience.
So when an end user comes in and
they talk to the Cloud Console,
their request to view
workload on the cluster
will route through
that connection, back
through the agent, and
ultimately to the API server.
The reason we did this
is probably obvious.
But if it's not, then I'll
do a quick explanation here.
So one is, we don't
really want people
to have to expose their
clusters to the public internet
if they're running on-prem.
And by having this
agent reach out
from there on-prem environment
or your other cloud provider
environment to
Google Cloud, we can
create an encrypted
connection back to GCP.
And it can traverse [INAUDIBLE]
and firewall rules--
sorry, egress firewalls.
We have proxy support.
And we can create that
long live connection
and provide a secure way to
access your cluster remotely.
The nice part about
this also is because we
are passing the end users--
so you saw the page that
Nakheel showed when we
went to log into the cluster.
We want every user to log in
with their own credentials.
And the reason we
want to do that is we
want your audit
logs in your cluster
to show a good audit
trail of what's
happening in that cluster.
So when the first person--
the administrator-- registers
a cluster, all that happens
is it shows up for everybody.
And everybody has to come
in and log in separately.
And they use their end user
credentials, like I said,
we're going to have really
good audit logs that end up
in the cluster.
So it makes auditing
really, really good.
So Wes mentioned also that
this doesn't extend to just GKE
On-Prem or other GKE clusters.
It really extends to bring
your own Kubernetes clusters.
And once we have
that agent installed,
we can do a lot of things.
So we mentioned the
single pane of glass.
But we're looking at integrating
with a lot of other services,
including the marketplace
and Stackdriver and a bunch
of other things to provide
the GKE experience really
for a lot of clusters
that aren't even GKE.
And with that, we'll wrap it up.
There's a couple
things here I'll note.
So one is that GKE On-Prem--
Kubernetes On-Prem-- is going
to be available in alpha
this fall.
And also that we
have a sign-up form.
I think we're missing the link.
So we'll put that up
right before we wrap.
But that's pretty much it.
So we'll take
questions offstage.
And thank you very
much for coming.
[MUSIC PLAYING]